-Benedict, since you've been
in so many fantastic movies
spanning so many genres,
I thought it'd be fun
if we put your movie knowledge
to the test.
It is time for "A to Z."
-♪ A to Z ♪
♪ A to Z ♪
-All right.
You probably call it "A to Zed."
I'm assuming
-I could do "Z."
It's fine.
-Here's how it'll work.
You're very nice.
You and I are going to
have a conversation
about our favorite movies,
but the catch is that each time
one of us brings up a new one,
the title has to start with
the next letter of the alphabet.
We're going to go back and forth
and see if we can get
all the way from A to Z.
You ready?
-Okay. Okay.
-Benedict, it's been such
a crazy year in quarantine.
I've watched nonstop movies,
and it's the best because
I obviously I had to start
with "Animal House."
-Yeah, yeah, I mean, you know,
and the thing about
"Animal House"
is how many "Bad Boys" there are
in that "Animal House."
-Yeah, yeah.
I mean, it reminded me
of "Chaplin" a little bit
because he was a bad boy,
because he didn't speak
in any of his movies, did he?
Yeah?
-Yeah, you're right.
You're right there.
Well, "Don't Look Now,"
but, you know...
-Of course.
I mean, did they sing?
'Cause they sang
in "Ever After."
Drew Barrymore...
-They did.
-Yeah, they sang a little bit.
-That's right.
But she was in "Forever Young,"
wasn't she?
Maybe she wasn't.
-Yeah, well, no,
she was in "Fever Pitch"
with me,
the American version.
-That's right. That's right.
She was not in "Goodfellas."
-No.
Or "High Society."
-No. And she wasn't in, um...
"I'll Fly Away."
Is that a movie?
-Hey, have you seen
"Jurassic Park"?
I saw "Jurassic Park."
It was a double feature.
I saw "Jurassic Park"
and then "Karate Kid,"
one after the other.
-No way.
And then there was
a third movie after that.
I couldn't remember what it was.
-Was it called "Lenny"?
[ Ding! ]
-Yes, it was "Lenny" --
it was the Lenny Bruce Story,
starring Dustin Hoffman.
That's --
-Yeah, not the things that --
[ Both laugh ]
-It's exactly correct.
-That would be
"Mission: Impossible."
Definitely.
-It definitely would be.
But I was about to say,
"One ticket for 'Notting Hill,'
please."
And that's not what
the one they gave me.
They gave me a ticket
to a different film.
"Out of Africa"?
-[ Ding! ]
-[ Laughs ]
Yep.
That's where music started.
That's where a cappella
music started.
And that's why they came up
with "Pitch Perfect."
that song about
singing and a capella.
Of course. Of course.
And then, I mean,
if you're talking about
singing movies, you know,
and I guess
you'd have to mention, uh...
[ Both laugh ]
It's so easy.
So easy.
-Uh, I'd just say "Queen,"
but that's not what it was.
-It's not?
Sure it is.
[ Both laugh ]
-Is it?
-Yeah, well, I mean,
it was called "Queen."
What did you think
it was called?
"Rock 'n' Roll High School"?
[ Ding! ]
-Yeah, I mean...
Yeah, something like that.
But it certainly wasn't called
"Star Wars."
We know that.
[ Ding! ]
-Yeah, but that did not work
as I believe.
I think it went down
like the "Titanic."
-Yeah, it must have done --
It must have gone
into the "Underworld."
-Yeah. Well, you know,
they came back to
because, you know,
"V for Vendetta."
You know,
they came back strong.
Ah, because that's absolutely --
Yeah.
But it was a wonder,
it was a wonder.
"Wonder Woman."
Yeah.
-She was.
She was a Wonder Woman,
just like Olivia Newton-John
was in "Xanadu."
[ Ding! ]
-In "Xanadu."
That's right.
And...
-X?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, "Xanadu," right?
Just a bunch of "Young Guns,"
basically, all of them.
-They were once young.
"Young Guns."
-Yep. Young.
They certainly were young,
young enough
to be a model in "Zoolander."
-Yes!
-I love you, dude!
I love you, man!
My thanks to
Benedict Cumberbatch.
His film, "The Courier,"
opens in theaters, March 19th.